good morning believe nation today's
message is fix it over to you Jonathan
gray the strategy is very simple we call
it buy it fix it and sell it we try to
buy income-producing real estate and a
discount to physical replacement costs
the cost of building that real estate we
go in and fix whatever's broken and then
once we complete whatever that mission
is we sell the asset to the right
long-term owner if you look at our track
record over a long period of time we've
invested in real estate assets office
building shopping centers hotels and yet
we've generated solid returns in good
and bad times and every one of our
investments we focus on the fix it
without the fix-it piece we can't have
success in virtually everything we do I
think in general entrepreneurs we fix
things we either build a business around
fixing something for ourselves and then
sharing that with the world or we're
fixing something for somebody else but
at the core of every entrepreneurial
venture is somebody who is fixing
something for somebody else we're the
builders were the creators entres the
people who are the problem solvers and
if you want to make more money if you
want to have more success and you want
to start adding value to other people's
lives and that comes from fixing
problems that they have so the question
of the day today is what do you do to
fix things for others leave it in the
comments below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events presently
this race to keep me going